[Music]
batman first hit the silver screen in
1943
and in the decades since he's been one
of hollywood's most accomplished heroes
in a dozen feature films we've seen a
truly incredible roster of caped
crusaders
and dark knights taking the character in
plenty of different directions
as prominent as he's been in film though
not all batman
are created equal here's our ranking of
every movie batman
from worst to best batman 1943
the thing you really have to understand
about the original batman serial
is that it's bad even by the standards
of the time
with 15 parts it's three and a half
hours of the worst version of batman to
ever hit the silver screen
batman and robin played by lewis wilson
and douglas croft
a recast here as government agents
tasked with stopping the villainous dr
dhaka from building a death ray and
creating an
army of zombies i have converted him
into a zombie
he can only act as i direct that might
sound exciting but it's atrocious and
repetitive with awful special effects
hilariously awkward costumes
unconvincing fights and
let's not forget america was at war with
japan at the time so they played up the
japanese bad guy as you'd expect
this batman is definitely best left
forgotten
batman and robin 1949 the only good
thing you can say about the second
batman serial is
that it's not as offensive as its
predecessor
it's still bad though the bumbling
barely present batman is trapped in an
awful plot
that stretches out even longer than the
first cereal with robert lowry's batman
stumbling from one goofy cliffhanger to
the next in an attempt to unmask
a mad scientist called the wizard after
four hours
surprise he turns out to be exactly the
guy you thought he was the whole time
the worst part though is the costume a
straight up
sweatsuit capped off with an ill-fitting
cow that makes him look
more like floppy-eared bunny rabbit man
batman forever 1995 in a movie that's
soaked in lime green neon and hot pink
leopard print
valkilma's portrayal of the caped
crusader is
well the kindest way to put it would be
reserved kilmore only two years removed
from a charismatic scene-stealing turn
as doc holliday in tombstone drifts
through batman forever with the scene
presence of a cardboard cutout
to be fair there was a good reason for
kilmer to make that choice
director joel schumacher was clearly
drawing his inspiration
from the 1966 television show and with
jim carrey and tommy lee jones chewing
their way through
every available bit of scenery
replicating adam west's
stentorian straight man probably seemed
like the best way to go
fully interactive holographs only a high
frequency carrier wave beamed directly
into the brain could create such images
there are parts where it works but when
it comes to actually
being batman his adam west impression
just
doesn't land it's especially rough in
his tepid romance with nicole kidman
as dr chase meridian the worst named
love interest in the franchise
and what a grand pursuit you must be
batman robin 1997 to say
batman and robin has a bad reputation is
putting it lightly
it's commonly regarded as one of the
worst superhero movies of all time
with a bloated cast of villains and
sidekicks sprawling out into a plot that
starts off silly
and ends up full on ludicrous it's so
bad that both joel schumacher
and george clooney have apologized for
it and it was credited with nearly
killing the franchise
until it returned with the darker
direction under christopher nolan
all right everyone
but as controversial as it might sound
clooney himself
is not actually that bad his effortless
charm doesn't really work for batman
but it actually does work pretty well
for bruce wayne if you can get past the
toy friendly suits
and their marble statue anatomy
clooney's best work
comes when he's out of the costume
sweeping around wayne manor and dealing
with alfred's
not quite fatal illness plus let's be
real here
even if clooney was as bad as the
movie's reputation would lead you to
believe
he'd still score bonus points for the
way he refers to dick grayson
when he gets mad she's infected us with
some sort of pheromone extract oh is
that what it is bruce i'm under some
kind of magic spell she wants to kill
you dick
batman the superman dawn of justice and
justice league
2016-2017 much of director
zack snyder's inspiration for batman v
superman came from frank miller's
landmark comic story the dark knight
returns
unfortunately while the movie definitely
lifted entire scenes wholesale from the
comics in an effort to please hardcore
fans they're all separated from the
original context
ben affleck's batman is a ludicrously
violent murderer who is easily
manipulated into a fistfight with
another superhero
which ends when the person he's fighting
reminds him that
other people also have mobs why did you
say that
it's his mother's name despite the
movie's silly plot coincidences
affleck's batman has some noteworthy
fight sequences
even if by this point the character
apparently gave up trying to uphold his
no
kill rule the lego batman movie 2017
the lego version of batman is the rarest
kind of satire
a parody of something that actually does
a great job at being the thing that it's
parodying
will arnett voices batman as a full-on
comedy character
he's got an obsession with darkness and
arnett ramps up his naturally gravelly
voice into a spoof of christian bales
at the same time though he's very rarely
presented as anything other than
extremely good at what he does an ultra
competent superhero who really does act
heroically
most of the time either way it works
while other portrayals might do their
best to move away from
the inherent silliness of a guy dressed
as a bat who primarily fights
murder clowns embracing it gives the
lego version a flavor that helps him
rival
even the best of his big screen
contemporaries
as funny as he might be he's still
batman in one of his purest forms
the dark knight trilogy 2005-2012
there's a moment in batman begins where
a crooked cop
gets snared by the ankle and hauled up
five stories in the middle of a
thunderstorm
so that a vigilante who looks like satan
himself can scream in his face
i don't know i swear to god
so yeah when you're describing christian
bale's performance
the word you want is intense bales
batman brings that level of intensity to
everything he does showing an emotional
range that stretches
from the righteous fury of batman to the
aimless pain
of the orphan bruce wayne who has denied
his vengeance
and even the quippy sarcasm of his
exchanges with alfred it's a powerful
portrayal
that's only ever matched when he goes up
against heath ledger's joker one
of the best performances in the genre
batman
batman returns 1989-1992
here's the thing about tim burton's
batman movies they're great timber
movies they have an incredible visual
style especially when it comes to gotham
city
it's a hellish industrial urban sprawl
slammed against
retro art deco where everyone still
dresses like it's 1940
and where purple knockout gas is a
deadly threat
against a monochromatic cityscape
they're full of great bits of satire
beautiful cinematography and the casting
is amazingly offbeat pitting our hero
against jack nicholson michelle pfeiffer
jack palance
and christopher walken the problem is
that dc
and warner brothers were still trying to
figure out what batman and bruce wayne
should be like in the modern era
the result was some awkward exchanges
between bruce wayne
and vicki vale as we see batman's human
side struggle
no one really captures that disconnect
more than michael keaton did when he put
on the cape and cow
he's actually kind of perfect for the
kind of remote mysterious weirdo
who sleeps upside down because he wants
to be more like a bat
now you wanna get nuts come on let's get
nuts but there's a difference between
the stylized goofiness the burden
explored in movies like
pee-wee's big adventure and beetlejuice
and the 80s action movie aesthetic that
saw keaton's batman blowing up buildings
full of criminals
batman's actions are mostly portrayed as
a personal quest for vengeance
that only incidentally winds up saving a
city
and that's a shame bruce wayne's
borderline psycho exchanges aside
michael keaton ultimately nails the dark
almost
spectral version of batman that
terrifies most of gotham's criminals
i want you to tell all your friends
about me what are you
i'm batman batman the movie
1966 the best thing about adam west's
performance in batman 66
is that it can mean completely different
things depending when you watch it
as a child it's easy to buy west's
batman is completely genuine
and as an adult once you're in on the
joke
the fact that he was able to play the
perfect straight man for a wild cast of
villains
is every bit as astonishing as those
surface level comic book thrills
the movie released on the big screen in
1966
between the first two seasons of the
show has everything
in a literal sense the arch villains
this time around are four of his
greatest
foes brought together as the united
underworld
revealed with a sequence in which batman
and robin identified their enemies
through
profound leaps of logic you mean when
there's a fish there could be a penguin
but wait
it happened at c see c for catwoman
at the same time it's easy to forget
that west is actually
really good as batman particularly when
he goes to save his love interest
miss kitka the links he's willing to go
and the heartbreak in his eyes when he
discovers that she was catwoman
all along even if you're watching it
with a healthy level of irony it's a
powerful moment
no actor has ever been as strongly
identified with the role of batman
as adam west and this movie shows
exactly why
his performance walks a delicate balance
between full-hearted adventure and witty
satire and the end result is perfect
he is and always will be the batman who
won't even risk hurting a bunch of baby
ducks
some days you just can't get rid of a
bomb
batman mask of the phantasm 1993
okay we'll admit that this one is a bit
of a cheat
kevin conroy has after all been the most
prominent batman actor for more than 25
years
making his debut on batman the animated
series and staying in the role
all the way through the arkham video
games but there's a good reason for that
conroy is an amazing batman and
everything that makes him great is on
display
in mask of the phantasm the film is the
first time that the animated series
really dug into batman's origin story
and conroy's performance sold it
beautifully the scene when
he's pleading with his parents graves
telling them he doesn't want to fight
crime because he's finally found
happiness is devastatingly emotional
i know i made a promise but i didn't see
this coming
i didn't count on being happy even
better is when that happiness is taken
away
and bruce gives himself over to his
mission entirely
for a generation of batman fans conroys
is the voice they hear in their heads
when they read comics
and that alone should show just how
great he was in the role
it takes an incredible amount of talent
to redefine the character
but that's exactly what kevin conroy did
in a way that
no other batman could